[Music]
hi leif look at me talking to you even
though i'm dead that's
trippy right well i'm still here
spiritually
i'm right behind you
that was a good one i got you i got you
i know yeah i did
i hereby leave my cabin to my son
provided he completes this
list of tasks left for him at the cabin
do you want a gun no should i no you'll
be fine
you'll be fine
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't really know my mom this list
could be anything
i know i wasn't the mother you wish i
did i did not
teach you enough stuff so i made this
list of lessons i learned to be most
important on this planet number one be
the predator
not the prey
who are you man your mom and i were
lovers i'm gonna miss you sweet girl
your mind your sense of humor your taste
in the morning
your next task call the one who got away
and say you're sorry hey audrey it's lee
i'm sorry is that a name or a word
we dated for three years why don't you
give me your phone number and then if i
can
remember who you are i'll just give you
a call back
you're so dumb oh buddy
sometimes life is messy it doesn't go as
you plan but it's not over
i'm too stoned for this
i want for you to experience the best of
this life will you come up here
and feel everything along the way
my biggest regret is that we didn't
spend any time together
i tell you a lot of stories about her
she's had quite an appetite
she was a very very sexual
animal and that's probably not what her
son wants to hear i guess
are you lingering don't linger stop the
tape please
i tried so hard to get this
you